[Musik]
sebastian lege zeigt euch wie bei
instant totally nissan erfüllung gespart
wird
günstige zutaten gut versteckt wir
wollen wissen die dass den italienern
schmeckt tortellini malacarne wird sich
ja richtig italienisch an keine
übersetzt fleisch 17% nudeln 30% füllung
und davon 38 prozent schweinefleisch
sommer so machen sind das ja nur zehn
prozent fleisch das muss ja mal eine
kleine brise seien günstige trocken
tortellini enthalten kaum fleisch sollen
aber trotzdem nach fleisch schmecken
darum streckt sebastian läge mit fleisch
pulver das wird unter anderem aus resten
der industriellen fleischverarbeitung
gewonnen und steckt zum beispiel in
vielen fertigsuppen es ist lange haltbar
kostet wenig und sorgt für einen
intensiven fleischgeschmack
[Musik]
ich muss ihn komisch aber hat fleisch
duft für die billigsten thate linie
aller zeiten setzt sebastian leger auf
eine weitere wunder zutat der industrie
damit es richtig intensiv fleisch
schmeckt fleisch aroma fehlt noch der
geschmacksträger möglichst günstig
natürlich und für den passenden schmelz
auf der zunge schmalz durch die ersatz
zutaten kann sebastian den fleischanteil
auf unter 10 prozent drücken
[Musik]
und jetzt der teig hier spart sebastian
läge nicht nur geld sondern auch zeit
denn statt frische eier aufzuschlagen
kommt bei ihm flüssiges vollei zum
einsatz
das ist ein gelb gemischt mit eiweiß
pasteurisiert länger haltbar und deshalb
billigt jetzt wollen wir natürlich wenig
füllung und schön viel teig damit
richtig profitabel wird denn selbst
unsere füllung mit minimalem
fleischanteil ist noch immer teurer als
der teig
jetzt müssen die tortellini noch
getrocknet werden nur so können sie
lange im regal liegen ohne zu verderben
der dampfgarer tötet die letzten keime
und der der automat entzieht die
feuchtigkeit
bei der beute liegen diese bricht die
trocken
die tortellini von produktentwickler
sebastian läge ein billigprodukt erster
güte da sind sie unsere tortellini
[Musik]
schmeckt oberried weiß experiment
gelungen
tortellini mit weniger als zehn prozent
fleisch füllung
kostenpunkt 60 cent pro portion in der
region venetien treffen sich jedes jahr
die weltbesten tortellini kirche hier in
vale do sul mincio feiern sie ein fest
und kochen um die wette
von den experten wollen wir wissen wie
gut sind handelsübliche tortellini aus
deutschland
[Musik]
unsere jury roberta paola und gianluigi
sie alle haben als einheimische
tortellini im blut
für uns testen sie zwei produkte aus der
trocken abteilung teuer aus dem bioladen
und die günstige eigenmarke von edeka
sowie drei mal frische tortellini aus
der kühltheke von lidl das markenprodukt
von steinhaus und die bio qualität wie
gut kommen die gefüllten nudeln aus den
verschiedenen preisklassen an
als erstes edekas trocken tortellini für
knapp vier euro das kilo
bestehen sie den kritischen
qualitätscheck ich muss leider sagen
schön sehen die nicht aus liebes knoten
nennen italiener ihre tortellini ist
genug amore drin
von liebe ist hier nicht die rede
durchgefallen weder die konsistenz noch
der geschmack noch datei der schmeckt
nach nichts
die tortellini von edeka fallen bei den
experten durch das zweite nun ein
produkt kommt von lidl und kostet
weniger als drei euro pro kilo
wie gut sind optik und geschmack
der total ohne sollte verschlossen
bleiben da sie maschinell gefertigt
werden
sie sind offen und der geschmack ist
einfach nicht da als würde man plastik
essen
[Musik]
die tester sind streng die discounter
nudeln fallen durch wir erhöhen und
schicken die marken totally von
steinhaus ins rennen
wie steht es um die qualität der einzige
positive aspekt ist dass alles gut
gekocht ist sowohl die verbindung als
auch der rest ja optisch schön
schmecken nicht sehen aber wenigstens
gut aus ein gnaden punkt für steinhaus
[Musik]
und es geht noch teurer
die bio variante kostet fast zwölf euro
pro kilo bekommt man dafür auch die
beste qualität dieser hier ist hart das
durchgekocht das bild ist nicht sehr
schön durch gefallen tut mir leid aber
weg mit ihr auch das teuerste produkt im
test fällt bei unserer stichprobe durch
mögen italiener vielleicht einfach keine
deutschen fertig nudeln letzte chance
zur ehrenrettung bio tortellini von
alnatura für knapp zehn euro pro kilo
die füllung schmeckt mir wenn wir den
anteil der füllung erhöhen dann haben
wir einen guten torte lohn
der gewinner der qualitäts checks die
biotonne loni von alnatura
hier macht sich der hohe preis bezahlt
[Musik]
die bilanz unseres tortellini tests
fällt bescheiden aus
wer sich das aufwendige selbermachen
sparen will greift jedoch besser zu den
nudeln aus der kühltheke denn die
getrockneten tortellini sind zumindest
in unserer stichprobe gnadenlos
durchgefallen beim tortellini fest von
vale do sul mincio konnten deutsche
liebes knoten nicht überzeugen
der teig zu fest die füllung zu wenig
und vor allem zu wenig am morgen
was sind eure lieblings tortellini
selbst gemacht oder die schnelle
alternative aus dem supermarkt sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips